GREG AND JESSE AND KIM
GUILFOYLE.
WE ARE LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY.
IT IS A WEEK FULL OF OUTRAGEOUS
AND OVER THE HILL COMMENTS FOR
ROSEANNE AND HER SHOW.
AND
>> IF IVANKA TRUMP CHOSE TO HAVE
THE MOST OBLIVIOUS TWEET.
THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL PHOTO OF YOU
AND YOUR CHILD.
ONE MOTHER TO ANOTHER.
DO SOMETHING ABOUT YOUR DAD'S
IMMIGRATION PRACTICE YOU
[BLEEP].
HE LISTENS TO YOU.
PUT ON SOMETHING TIGHT AND LOW
CUT AND TELL YOUR [BLEEP] AND
TELL HIM IT WAS AN OBAMA THING
AND SEE HOW IT GOES.
>> Dana: THE WHITE HOUSE SAID
THE COMMENTS WERE VILE AND
VICIOUS AND SHE RESPONDED SHE
CROSSED THE LINE.
BUT MICHAEL MOORE CALLED IT
A BRILLIANT RANT AND SALLY
FIELDS IS SHOWING SUPPORT WITH
A VULGAR TWEET OF HER OWN.
AND CATHY GRIFFIN GOING AFTER
SARAH SANDERS.
>> THE PRESIDENT POINTED TO THE
MEDIA SAYING HORRIBLE THINGS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND NO BODY
ADDRESSES IT.
WHERE WAS THE APOLOGY FOR KATHY
GRIFFIN GOING ON A PROFANE RANT
OF THE PRESIDENT ON THE VIEW
AFTER A PHOTO OF HER HOLDING THE
PRESIDENT'S HEAD.
>> DON'T CALL FOR ME AND FOR F-
SAKE TAKE A COLD READING CLASS
AND MAYBE YOU WILL NOT STUMBLE
SO MUCH AND THERE IS HEAVY METAL
BAND, PUNK BAND.
AND THAT WAS DROPPED FROM THE
MUSIC FESTIVAL FOR JOKING ABOUT
THE VICTIMS OF THE LAS VEGAS
SHOOTING.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THAT AT LEAST THEY WERE
COUNTRY FANS.
>> Dana: SO IT'S THURSDAY AND
TGIF TOMORROW AND QUITE A WEEK
FOR ALL OF THESE KINDS OF
THINGS.
GREG, I WILL TURN IT OVER TO YOU
AND BRING IT BACK TO EARTH.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> Greg: IT FEELS LIKE WE ARE ON
AN OUTRAGE SUPER HIGHWAY AND
DRIVEN BY EMOTION THAT CREATES
MOMENTS AND PEOPLE SAY THING AND
IN THOSE MOMENTS IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR SCALPS, RIGHT?
AND THEN IF I DON'T LIKE YOUR
POLITICS, I WILL GET YOUR SCA L,
VICE VERSA AND COMPANIES FIRE
PEOPLE AND SUSPEND AND THEY SEE
THE PITCHFORKS AMASSING AS
A MOB.
BUT HERE IS THE THING, YOU KNOW,
SAMANTHA BEE APOLOGIZED AND I
BELIEVE YOU SHOULD ACCEPT AN
APOLOGY EVEN THOUGH NO ONE WILL
RETURN THE FAVOR TO ME.
>> Geraldo: I APOLOGIZE.
>> Greg: PEOPLE ARE COMING AFTER
YOU AND WAITING FOR YOU TO SLIP
UP AT ANY MOMENT AND THERE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE PAID
MILLIONS THAT HAVE SPONSORS THAT
WAIT FOR US TO SCREW UP SO THEY
CAN GO AFTER YOUR ADVERTISERS
AND LIVELIHOOD AND CAREER.
BUT WE DON'T DO THAT.
I WOULD NOT SAY THAT TO SAMANTHA
BEE.
SHE APOLOGIZED AND THAT IS FINE.
BUT I KNOW THAT THERE IS AN
INDUSTRY OF KNIVES WAITING FOR
ALL OF US.
WE HAVE TO DO IT BACK TO THEM
AND IT WAS A MUTUALLY ASSURED
DESTRUCTION.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
WHY DON'T YOU STOP THAT.
>> YOU MEAN ALL OF US.
PEOPLE ARE PAID TO MONITOR FOX
NEW AND WAIT FOR TO YOU SAY
SOMETHING.
>> Geraldo: MY GOODNESS, GREG,
THE C- WORDS THE EQUIVALENT OF
THE WORD.
IT IS DISGUSTING AND YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT LOOKING FOR
A PERSON TO SLIP UP.
THIS WAS NOT A SLIP UP.
IT WAS A ASSAULT ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SAYING, I AM
WILLING TO ACCEPT THE APOLOGY
EVEN THOUGH NO ONE WOULD ACCEPT
OURS.
>> Dana: I WOULD SAY THE WAY WE
ARE ALL RAISED THAT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
>> Geraldo: ACCEPT THE APOLOGY.
>> Dana: WHEN ROSEANNE BARR HER
TWEET AND APOLOGY AND SAID I WAS
ON AMBIEN AND TRIED TO BLAME
THAT.
THIS WAS SOMETHING, I DON'T KNOW
IF SAMANTHA BEE INTENDED OR
WROTE IN THE SCRIPT THE C- WORD.
>> Geraldo: IT SOUNDED LIKE IT
WAS SCRIPTED.
THE CROWD LOVED IT.
>> Dana: IS THAT WHY PEOPLE DO
THIS?
>> Geraldo: GREG SUGGESTED
BEFORE THE SHOW MAYBE SHE
PRE-MEDITATED THIS BECAUSE HER
RATINGS WERE LAGGING.
I ASKED ABOUT HER RATINGS.
TO ME, THIS IS IT A LARGER
PROBLEM, AND PARTICULARLY ABOUT
IVANKA, I THINK THAT TO ATTACK
IVANKA FOR HER FATHER IS UNFAIR.
REMEMBER YOUR TENURE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE KIDS.
THIS IS NOT A KID.
THIS IS A FULLY MATURE WOMAN AND
ENTREPRENEUR.
>> Dana: JUST WORKING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Geraldo: FOR NO PAY AS HER
HUSBAND IS.
THEY ARE BRILLIANT AND MOST
UNDERESTIMATED IN WASHINGTON AND
EASY MARKS FOR PEOPLE LIKE
SAMANTHA BEE TO BE SNOTTY AND
ATTACK AND TRY TO TEAR DOWN.
AND I THINK THAT THIS WAS AN
ABSOLUTELY PRE-MEDITATED AND I
BUY IN GREG'S POINT PARTIALLY IT
WAS PRE-MEDITATED BECAUSE OF THE
RATINGS AND LOOK AT ME, LOOK AT
ME.
AND NUMBER TWO, TO USE THIS
VICIOUS.
I MEAN THE C WORD.
IT IS LIKE ROSEANNE.
SOME PLACES YOU JUST CAN'T GO
ANYWHERE.
WE HAVE EVOLVED PAST THAT.
>> Dana: THERE WERE QUICK
DECISIVE CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
ROSEANNE AND IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE IT WILL BE FOR SAMANTHA
BEE.
>> Jesse: NO, THE MEDIA WILL SAY
SHE MOVED ON AND ON TO THE NEXT
MARK.
COULD BE GREG, WE ARE ALL
WAITING FOR IT.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU ARE
PROBABLY RIGHT.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THE
CWORDS EQUIVALENT TO THE N WORD.
NOT TO SAY IT IS NOT BAD.
BUT I WOULD NOT EQUATE WHAT
ROSEANNE SAID TO SAMANTHA.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU SLICE OR
DICE IT.
BUT NOT AS UGLY AS THE N- WORD.
SHE'S LOOKING FOR ATTENTION AND
LIKE A CRY FOR HELP.
SHE'S NOT A TALENTED COMEDIAN
AND NOT ON THE COLBERT.
SHE IS A MANTHA BEE LIST.
AND SHE IS TRYING TO BE FILTHY.
AND I ASK PEOPLE AT FOX NEWS AND
THEY DO ALL OF THE NUMBER
CRUNCHING.
GIVE ME A LIST OF OTHER NASTY
STUFF SHE SAID.
I HAVE THREE PAGES OF DEROGATORY
SEXUAL SLURS SHE USED AGAINST
THE MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP FAMILY
AND ALMOST EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM.
>> Greg: DON'T BE A TEASE.
>> Jesse: IT IS ALL BAD.
AND SOME OF THE WORST STUFF SHE
RESERVED FOR THE WOMEN.
KELLY ANN CONWAY.
[BLEEP] AND F--- SARAH SANDERS.
WHETHER CHELSEA HANDLER AND
SAMANTHA BEE.
THEY SAVE THE WORST FOR THE
WOMEN.
WHETHER IT IS MELANIA, OR IVANKA
OR SARAH SANDERS.
THEY GO NUTS ON THESE PEOPLE.
>> THEY ARE MAD BECAUSE THEIR
GIRL DIDN'T WIN.
AND I FEEL LIKE THE COMEDIANS
WENT FROM BEING FUNNY TOANGRY.
AND I LIKE THE WORD SNOTTY.
WE ARE WATCHING ADULT MEAN GIRLS
ALL OF THE TIME.
AND I THINK COMEDIANS HAVE
A HARD JOB, YOU WANT TO BE FUNNY
BUT NOT TOO UNPOLITICALLY
CORRECT OR DID I OFFEND ANYBODY.
BUT COMEDY SHOULD BE FUNNY AND
THIS IS NOT FUNNY.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IS HAVING
A PROBLEM AND SHE IS TURNING
INTO A MEAN GIRL SEEING WHAT SHE
CAN SAY.
THIS HAD TO BE SCRIPTED AND
PEOPLE HEARD IT.
AND THIS WAS A NETWORK DECISION
TO RELEASE THIS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW IT IS IT
AN OFF THE CUFF.
>> Jesse: NOT A LIFE SHOW.
AND EVERYBODY ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE TOP BRASS KNEW IT.
>> THEY HAVE TO LOOK HOW THEY
HANDLE IT.
AND THEN PEOPLE JUMP AND SAID IS
THERE A IDEOLOGICAL REASON?
GET FIRED AND NOT.
WE LIVE IN A DAY AND AGE AND NOT
TOLERATE MEAN AND NASTY STUFF.
THAT IS NOT FUNNY MEANT TO MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL BAD OR BE RACIST,
YOU HAVE TO DO IT ACROSS THE
BOARD.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK SHE WILL
BE CANNED.
CBS IS NOT THINKING THEY WILL
LOSE.
SHE MAY GAIN VIEWERS.
ROSEANNE, I THINK PEOPLE WOULD
TURN IT OFF.
>> I WOULD BE INCLINED TO ACCEPT
THE APOLOGY.
THERE HAS TO BE A POLICY HERE
AND NOT ONE PERSON SAID
SOMETHING HEINOUS AND DISGUSTING
AND THEY LOSE THEIR JOB.
AND ANOTHER PERSON KEEP THEIR
JOB AND GET PROMOTED THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> Greg: IT GOES BACK TO WHAT
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER SAID IN THE
'80s.
THE RIGHT THINKS YOU ARE WRONG
AND THE LEFT THINGS YOU ARE
EVIL.
AND THAT DEFINES THE SELECTIVE
OUTRAGE AND MEANING THAT SOMEONE
CAN GET AWAY SAYING SOMETHING
HEINOUS ABOUT YOU BECAUSE YOU
ARE EVIL.
BULLPEN I SAY SOMETHING
DISGUSTING ABOUT ANY LIBERAL
THEY WILL GO HOW CAN YOU DO
THAT?
THAT IS DISGUSTING AND YOU ARE
A TERRIBLE PERSON.
IT IS THAT DIVIDE.
THEY THINK YOU ARE EVIL AND WE
THINK THEY ARE WRONG.
AND THAT CREATES THE CULTURE.
>> Jerry: MAKING EXCUSES.
>> Greg: YOU ARE THE BAD PERSON.
>> Jesse: THEIR POLITICAL AGENDA
IS SO RIGHTOUS THEY ALLOW FOR
THINGS LIKE THIS TO HAPPEN.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT THE SELF
POLICING OF YOUR OWN SIDE?
>> Greg: YOU MENTIONED THE BAD
AND NO AFFECTS.
THEY MADE A JOKE ABOUT THE
SHOOTING OF THESE PEOPLE AND
SAID THEY WERE COUNTRY MUSIC
FANS.
AND TO THAT LIBERAL FAN, COUNTRY
MUSIC FANS ARE RACIST RED NECKS
AND THE JOKE IS OKAY AND THEY
ARE BAD PEOPLE.
>> Geraldo: I THINK IT IS
ANOTHER POINT HAVING TO DO WITH
TIMING.
I MADE MY SHARE OF GAFFES AND
THE TIMING OF YOUR APOLOGY IS
CRITICAL.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF YOU APOLOGIZE AS
SAMANTHA BEE AS ROSEANNE DID
HOURS AFTER YOU TALK TO YOUR PR
MORE THAN AND MANAGEMENT AND
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER AND SEEN THE
AUDIENCE REACTION, I GIVE THAT
LITTLE CREDIT.
AND I DON'T IN ANY WAY, IT
DOESN'T ABSOLVE THE SIN.
IF YOU DO IT IMMEDIATE.
AND OH, MY GOD I SCREW UP AND
HIT THE SEND BUTTON AND I WISH I
COULD GET THAT BACK.
AND IF THERE IS A SPONTANEOUS
APOLOGY WHERE IT COMES FROM THE
SOUL AND YOU ARE YOUR OWN
POLICEMEN AND MONITOR AND
RESPONDING TO YOUR OWN MISDEED